so there's a great term coined by the
philosopher Foucault known as
heterotopia now a heterotopia is a space
and once physical and inter psychic that
can be designed through the careful
curation of location and individual's
right to create literally a space of
mind that people can go mingle with
within so think of a excellently curated
conference like Summit Series where
individuals come together who share a
series of passions and curiosities in
two outrageously well staged and
designed spaces that inform and and
condition the mood that emerges and so
the reality the epidemiological plan the
collective buzz the theater of
experience that is created by the
curation and the design it becomes again
a space of mind that we can dwell in
together we're talking about designer
mind escapes that can be shared
communally places like Burning Man
perhaps embodiments to its full
potential literally a world created out
of the imagination a temporary dwellings
place a liminal zone a space between
this world and the other where we can
experience the imaginal together where
we can italicize reality and create
world hoods and live within those world
hoods together and mate with each
other's minds and it is so awesome and
so I think we should just like start
using this term now when we design these
spaces of experience in the 21st century
we engage more and more the technical
material of subjectivity itself as Eric
Davis says just built better and better
and Tobias as packed Kane wrote in his
beautiful book the clay ethnic let's go
play
cognitive play is where it's at